marie paule ville assiégée depuis fin
février la prise de contrôle de la ville
par la russie ne serait plus qu'une
question de jours actuellement oui vous
savez la ville a été détruite à 90% donc
vous allez me dire qu'est ce qui est
dans les 10 % qui résiste encore
la ville de marioupol a été détruite à
la fois par des bombardements aériens
russes à la fois par des missiles qui
l'on tirait depuis les avions et des
bateaux par donc ils sont en mer et puis
parce qu'il ya eu beaucoup de combats
dans la ville beaucoup de combat parce
que il y à des ukrainiens qui se bat
mais il ya surtout à marioupol les
milices d'azov donc on avait pointé du
doigt par leur rôle et leurs
accointances avec les nazis mais qu'ils
se sont installés vers 2014 à marioupol
et donc c'est un de leurs terrains
j'allais dire de bataille est donc ce
sont des miliciens très aguerris qui
savent se battre et donc les combats ont
été particulièrement rude avec les
russes et c'est pour ça que ça dure sur
plusieurs jours or aujourd'hui ceux qui
restent qui n'a pas été détruit à
marioupol c'est une usine d'acier qui
est un grand bâtiment du cou qui servait
à voir des grands hangars dans lequel il
y à des caves en dessous et donc c'est
un terrain qui est extrêmement difficile
si l'on doit se retrouver entre
combattants etc ce local cette usine qui
est à l'est de marioupol qui sert en
fait de refuge et c'est pour ça que les
russes là encore donc quelques jours à
combattre avec effectivement des
miliciens aguerris les troupes russes se
concentrent actuellement sur le dombass
et vladimir poutine a besoin d'une
victoire à n'importe quel prix l armée
l'ukrainienne at elle les moyens de
résister dans le donbass alors l'armée
ukrainienne dans le nom basse fait
preuve d'un immense courage
indéniablement considère qu' à peu près
trente mille soldats qui sont lassés des
gens là encore qui ont l'habitude de
combattre parce que les combats existe
en fait dans cette zone a depuis 2014 et
les harpes et ukrainienne combattez avec
les pro russe dans cette zone là ils
connaissent ce territoire ils savent se
battre simplement c'est vrai qu'ils
commencent à être fatigués on est un
certain nombre de jours et qu ensuite si
on regarde comment vont se passer en
fait l'arrivée des russes c'est qu'ils
vont être pris en fait en taille avec et
des russes qui arrive de l'est classique
qui arrive du nord et maintenant s'ils
libèrent marioupol ça va leur permettre
de faire une trajectoire qui donc du
coup va olé les ukrainiens donc quelle
que soit la qu'habite la qualité de leur
combat on va se retrouver avec des gens
qui vont être coupés de kiev qui vont
être coupés de tout les possibilités de
ravitaillement qui vont arriver les
russes sont bons coups bombarder quand
on regarde le territoire ukrainien a des
fois il ya des lieux on se dit pourquoi
est-ce qu'ils sont là en fait c'est
parce qu'il ya c'est des endroits de
stockage de pétrole pour les chars par
exemple pour les ukrainiens alors les
américains sont intervenus ils ont dit
on va donner du renseignement aux
ukrainiens on va leur donner la lecture
la plus importante sur ce que font les
russes autour d'eux ils leur ont donné
des missiles maintenant on le sait ils
vont leur fournir des drones kamikaze
qui était jusqu'à présent pas rentrer
sur le territoire ukrainien et les
américains formeraient en pologne
justement les ukrainiens pour s'en
servir ce qui dans ce cas là leur donne
des drones avec une petite charge donc
vous lancez le drone est ensuite au
moment où vous voulez vous le dites vous
le déclencher et donc ça va exploser
donc ça peut faire beaucoup de mal aux
russes mais les combats vont être
compliqué sachant que dans ces cas là
les russes vont faire du combat
d'artillerie 24 heures sur 24 heures
jusqu'à ce que tout cela craquant fait
et la date dont vous parliez c'est le 9
mai est effectivement vladimir poutine a
besoin pour les cérémonies du 9 mai qui
sera équivalent du 8 mai en france
d'avoir un succès merci beaucoup armelle
cherrih